hello everyone and welcome to uh two
really incredible games from the
semi-finals of the women's fide World
Cup we have uh Anna music of Ukraine
versus
of course needs no introduction she won
pretty much everything there is to win
in the chess world except that
prestigious title of the actual women's
world champion and uh of course you
would very much like to qualify for the
candidates tournament the challenge the
reigning world champion Juve engine for
the title but it hasn't been easy
because uh well well for example hoi
ifan was competing you just couldn't win
and she she won the World Championship
four times then you had your engine is
now four years in a row world champion
tanjongi uh also one two times then
before that you had an ocean and also
Anna's sister Maria muzichuk was I
believe 2015 uh women's world champion
uh and okay you had a couple of um other
names
um you know long long time ago like
Alexander costenuk maybe in 2008 and uh
bit before that Antonio stefanova and
well it's a you know it's not easy to
win everything but of course she she
wants to try and uh opposing her is
nurul salimova of Bulgaria who is not
even a grand master she is an
international master and she's just
crushing everyone with a very very
impressive style of play she just you
know sacrifices upon sacrifices the
second Pawn goes for the attack and she
crushes her opponent so how will this
fare against Tana muzu let's check it
out and see what happened in this
matchup and who will face Alexander
goriacina in the finals of the affiliate
Women's World Cup so let's check it out
Animusic has the white pieces and she
opens with Ponte E4 we have Pawn to C6
uh salimova goes for the karokan defense
D4 D5 we have Knight the C3 and the D
captures on e4 so the uh the accepted
variation Knight captures an E4 the main
line and now Knight to F6 and I was
always annoyed when someone played this
against me with the black pieces yeah
because uh I know the top movies the
capture on F6 and I really hate trading
pieces early on in the opening so I was
always trying to move the Knight
somewhere but it's just not very good I
mean you play something like Knight to
G3 already H5 is coming followed by C5
and it's just um black is getting all of
this control play for nothing okay you
have to capture an F6 of course Anna
does that with a cap press on F6 and now
Pawn to C3 uh strengthening the center
here Bishop to D6 with Bishop to D3 and
here we have castles we have Queen to C2
and now Rook the E8 with check with
Bishop to E3 and now uh Pawn to H5 as
the pawn was hanging on H7 so you might
as well Advance it all the way we have
Knight to F3 Knights to D7 and here we
have Queen side castles of course you're
not gonna Castle King side it would be
silly here Queen side castles and you
want to start attacking that black king
and here there is a game where Knight to
f8 was played but here we have Pawn to
B5 uh Salim of a ghost for the attack
and it is now as of movie 11 that we
have a completely new game so uh by
playing B5 of course you weaken the C6
pawn and Anna tries to exploit that by
playing Pawn to D5 this also weakens the
B5 Pawn
uh and salima finds a very very
interesting way of how to sacrifice for
the attack she plays Pawn to C5 now it
gives up the B5 pawn and you really
should capture this otherwise you I mean
you just allowed this free expansion of
the BNC Pawn so Bishop captures on B5
and now Rook to B8 okay so for the price
of one Pawn you get to Rook on the
semi-openv file we have Bishop to C6 and
now comes Rook to E7 just nicely on
pinning uh we have H3 now of course you
want to start expanding on the king side
to go after the black king and Knight to
B6 and now of course you don't want to
see the Knight on C4 so Knights the D2
and now Pawn to F5 okay making some
progress for the price of that one pawn
and here you should really consider a
move like Bishop to G5 it's uh okay it
for it um uh forces black to play F6 and
now after you move you might even allow
this but okay your Bishop is out of the
game for the moment but you weaken the
blacks King side uh substantially and
you can now start undermining those
spawns will move like G3 H4 and then
you're gonna get your pieces back into
the game but in the game night the B3
was played going after the C5 Pawn but
it doesn't matter as of course prepared
for that Knight the C4 now the Knight
cannot move from B3 because Rook capture
some B2 would just ended the game so
here we have Rook hde1 centralizing both
of the Rooks and now Knight captures on
E3 also F4 was a very interesting choice
with f characters and now Pawn to G6 so
you don't have to worry about your Pawn
here we have Knight back to D2 now the
Knight is coming to C4 and Bishop to G3
okay attacks The Rook we have rookie two
and now Bishop to A6 and look how all of
a sudden uh Noodle's Bishops uh come
alive the the bishop a very nicely
placed on this diagonal in this bishop
on this diagonal so if you don't want to
lose the Rook you absolutely have to
play Pawn to C4 so Pawn to C4 is played
and now we have Bishop to E5 again very
nicely going after the B2 pawn and now
we have Pawn to B3 so okay you've
created this beautiful punching here but
this also somehow somewhat weakens white
uh Queen side and a look at this
beautiful attacking move by salimova
Bishop back to G7 this frees up the path
for the black queen to enter the attack
via the F6 square or maybe via the A5
Square could all be very very important
later on we have pawned the E4 and now
Bishop to C8 now it's time to shift the
bishop over to the other diagonal and
this is also a very instructive way of
how to how to consider candidate moves
your opponent plays E4 and you're
thinking alright I don't want to see e
captures on F5 uh you know in this
position and I also don't like my Bishop
on A6 it's it's pretty useless piece so
we combine the two uh you know useless
ideas and we make a useful one Bishop to
C8 just defends F5 and now he captures
an F5 is something why they definitely
doesn't want to do and allow the bishop
to gain control of this diagonal so also
very useful way of thinking about your
candidate moves rook dte1 and now F
captures an E4 we have Rook captures on
e4 Rook captures an E4 and now you have
to play Knight captures on e4 to control
the F6 square but here we have Queen
captures on e4 and now Queen to F6 is
crushing but the salima does not play it
probably because Queen to F6 uh okay
maybe you don't see the the follow-up
but after Bishop to F5 it's very hard to
to find the move for white she does
something very similar uh only she
doesn't go with the queen to F6 she goes
Queen to A5 she still wants to get to
the C3 square but now we have Queen to
F4 attacking the rook and B8 and now
look at this queen to C3 with check King
to D1 and now of course you cannot
continue the attack because the Rook on
V8 is hanging or can you that's exactly
what you always have to ask yourself uh
Bishop to F5
uh not just sacrificing The Rook but
sacrificing The Rook uh with with check
I mean who who does that look at this
and now the only way to survive this
position is to not capture The Rook of
course you have to play Rook to E3 still
black will be better let's say queen day
one checking T2 but you are you are
surviving but after this bishop to F5
move uh Anna accepted the free rook the
queen capture some B8 was played because
it comes with check who could resist
that uh King to H7 and now Queen back to
F4 seemingly uh defending against
everything but now look at this bishop
to H6 and now look at this Mighty Bishop
pair I I'd say this is worth more than
one Rook uh Queen to F2 you have to
guard the Knight otherwise is just
Checkmate the queen and Bishop do a very
good job going after the Knight and here
we have Bishop the C2 with check and
this is the only way to end the game
it's basically a force to Checkmate in
three uh because if you start with Queen
to C2 check and okay even you win the
Knight here the King goes to F1 well
there's no continuation you're just done
with material you're down the exchange
and the the past Depot will destroy you
but after Bishop to C2 There Is No
Escape it's a forced mate and of course
it was in this position on move 32 that
um uh anamuzichuk resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
now if King to C1 of course is the the
oldest trick in the book Bishop to D3
check now guards D2 Square King D1 and
queen to C2 will be Checkmate and if you
don't do that if you start running away
with the King well then it's just a
meeting one with Queen to D3 so uh very
nicely done by uh by salimova with the
black pieces and let me just uh load uh
sorry not that I need to load something
real quickly because I have to uh switch
uh colors I even prepared this for you
uh so we don't have the all right so
there we have nope not that sorry about
that sorry just give me give me one
second
very strange that I don't have it here
oh it's there okay
there we go
uh I have I haven't saved it oh man
that's this really really silly of me uh
so okay you can just rewind let's say uh
30 seconds while I while I do this it's
gonna take me like 30 seconds to achieve
this
sorry about that I did do it I just have
no idea why the computer didn't save it
so sorry about that
really hate it when that happens
there we go
there we go all right
sorry about that
ah there we go really sorry uh so uh
this is the second game that we are
showing salimova now has the white
pieces uh because uh this was the first
game of the rapid that we've just shown
and then Anna retaliated in the second
game also with the black pieces and now
this is the faster rapid this was the 25
minute rapid section this is the 10
minute rapid section and now salimova is
the one with the white pieces and again
this game is just it's something uh
something that you would expect uh you
know uh if morphe played Anderson on a
bad day that that's what this game is
like I mean look at this spawn to D4 by
nurio we have Ponte D5 and now c4 and
Anna of course goes for D captures and
C4 she goes for the Queen's Gambit
accepted and it is the I believe the new
way to play nowadays if you really want
to have um uh winning Chances with black
here uh you know with sharpest lines as
possible Knight F3 we have Knight to F6
E3 E6 and now Bishop captures and C4 we
have Pawn to C5 again the absolute main
line of the Queen's Gambit find all top
moves we have castles here and pawn to
A6 and here Believe It or Not uh salimua
plays the 12th most popular move in the
position here the captures on C5 is the
most popular any other move you can
imagine B3 or I mean they're all very
much playable but Rook to E1 is the 12th
most uh most played move and it has been
played before by some very strong names
like mamidaro plated alireza played the
grish who played at um played at
grigorioparin even defeated Hans Neiman
with Rook D1 but all in all Maybe
30 maybe 30 to 50 games all in all
played with this Rook D1 move so it's uh
very very rare and it's very hard to
imagine that Anna has something prepared
for this so Knight to C6 Knight to C3
and now Pawn to B5 of course you chase
away the bishop Bishop back to D3 and
now Bishop to B7 sold a pretty standard
setup of the Queen's Gambit declined A4
and now Pawn to B4 we have knighted to
E4 and C characters on D4 and this is a
well-known position it has been reached
in the town Memorial Tournament of um
2021 it was the so-called lindoris Abbey
tournament uh and Alexander pretke had
it against Olga badelka where uh in that
game he captures and D4 was played but
here we have Knight captures and F6 and
it is not as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game so okay G captures
on F6 e captures on D4 and now Knight to
A5 and it's a very useful move of course
you control the B3 and C4 squares in the
future you might go B3 you might go
Bishop to D5 to C4 you might go Bishop
to D5 Knights the c4u might go Bishop to
B5 Bishop to B3 also The Rook is coming
to E8 so you will have full control over
that C4 uh Square so Knight day five
definitely makes sense with Bishop to F4
uh and now Rook the C8 by Anna we have
Queen to E2 and now Bishop to D6
countering this strong bishop and F4 but
now Bishop to H6 and now look at this
position what do you make of this
uh Anna's King is an E8 uh and okay uh
it can't really Castle but how safe is
it how safe is that King there with uh
the queen and the Rook occupying the E
file well Knight to B3 attacks The Rook
with Rook 8 to D1 and now comes Queen to
A5 Anna struggling to find moves here as
uh well there just aren't any and uh
yeah nurul takes advantage of this
remarkably with Pawn to D5 and now the
problem is you cannot allow D captors on
E6 that just ends the game and of course
if Bishop captures which is Black's only
move then you no longer defend the A6
pawn and look at what happens here
Bishop captures on D5 Bishop captures an
A6 attacks the rook and now Rook the C5
with Bishop to B5 with check nicely the
pawn on A4 defense the bishop here King
to B8 is of course the f8 square is
covered and now comes Bishop to E3
attacking The Rook here Rook the C7 was
played by Anna but now feel free to
pause the video and try to find the the
absolutely crushing a series of moves
that you know end the game on the spot
uh while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook
captures on D4 we can also do that in
slow motion but no there is another move
I want to do in slow motion uh so okay e
characters and D5 and now comes the move
you had to see in order to play Rook
captures on D5 and that of course is
Bishop the B6 look at this bishop comes
to B6 and you might be wondering about
why Bishop to B6 aren't we just giving
away a free piece here yes but what
about Queen to E8 isn't that just
Checkmate yes it is and of course it was
in this position on move 23 that Anna
muzichuk resigned in the game and uh
well as there is nothing more to be done
here and nurio salimova goes into the
finals of the women's video World Cup
where she will face Alexander goyacchina
uh for the uh for for first place of the
of the video World Cup she already
qualifies for the candidates tournament
and uh interestingly I thought that if
you qualify for the candidates you
automatically get your Grandmaster I
don't like Boba Fisher he qualified for
the candidates tournament and they just
gave him the uh the Grand Master title
he didn't have it back then but she
doesn't get it she only gets a grand
master Norm only if she gets first place
in the video World Cup so if she defeats
Alexander
then she will be immediately granted the
Grand Master title but okay I mean if
she if she already is in the finals of
defeated World Cup if she's going to the
candidate she will no doubt achieve the
the Grand Master title uh soon enough
but it would be I don't know if you
already get to the candidates tournament
you should have um you know maybe be
granted the Grand Master title but at
least it's gonna be really really
awesome if she actually wins the
candidates tournament with an
international Master title and imagine
if we had an international Master being
a a a world champion I mean that'd be
just that'd be just really weird but
okay yeah and for those of you who are
wondering why she resigned I did explain
it but maybe you'd like me to show it
there's no move here I mean you either
give up the queen or or even if you give
up the queen it doesn't really matter
after here she will just sacrifice the
queen and after Rook captures Rook
captures and it will be Checkmate and
this happens regardless of what you do
you can take the bishop you can ignore
the bishop you can you can run away with
King to see it okay then you don't um
then you just lose the queen but still I
mean it's uh what a wonderful wonderful
position I mean when's the last time
you've seen something like this
absolutely crushing uh so yeah that's
the game or rather those were the games
hope you guys enjoyed it very nicely
done by salimova we'll see we'll see how
she will do against Alexander who is
also you know an absolute Beast she just
crushes everyone
and uh it's gonna be it's gonna be a you
know a real fight so uh stay tuned for
that uh I would like to thank srinivas
kashyap bullet chess thriller.com
and Yoon Yang for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Fida
World Cup until it finishes so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and really
sorry about not having the template
ready I have no idea how it happened I
mean really sorry about that uh see you
soon